in some ways they look and act much like
us
now come stunning new evidence that
gorillas may also think like us this
incredible series of photographs taken
deep in the African Congo and revealed
here
for the first time show what some
researchers thought was impossible proof
that wild gorillas can think through
problems and like humans they can make
and use tools to solve those problems
Wildlife Conservation Society scientist
Emma Stokes and Thomas Brewer believe
the discovery gives us new insight into
the mind of the great ape Thomas's
observation of tweezing behavior by
gorillas in Bali was was a it was a
fantastic discovery it was made here in
this remote research outpost at him
belly by
the swampy forest clearing in the
northern Congo where frolicking
elephants create pools of turgid water
one morning Brewer witnesses something
extraordinary and manages to capture it
on film a female gorilla named Lea grabs
a stick and appears to use it as a tool
to measure the depth of the water before
crossing a patch of swampy ground this
is an amazing and scientifically
important moment but for Brewer is also
a very familiar experience when I I
cross a swamp I always use a kind of
stake to test the water deepness and
what's fascinating is that these
gorillas found exactly the minds domain
the same solution to this problem
with these extraordinary photographs WCS
scientists for the first time have
documented the use of tools among wild
gorillas something never seen before we
know that in the in the past we claim
that Tullius is a unique feature of our
own species but we know that that not
the case any longer animals are able to
plan that thing and they define a
solution to a problem for years now
we've known some animals use tools
especially in the pursuit of food these
chimpanzees are experts at brandishing
clubs to crack open nuts passing their
skills on to the next generation
they use sticks to fish out insects and
leaves like cups to scoop up water but
until now while gorillas were not
considered tool users some in captivity
have used sticks to eke out a tasty
treat but this behavior was never
observed in the wild and there was more
in another stroke of luck one month
later Brewer witnesses a second gorilla
inventing a tool a female named Effie
drives a branch into the ground and uses
it as an anchor as she reaches into the
water Apes itand belly by have been
known to hang on to trees in order to
pull themselves from the swamps but this
is the first time a gorilla is seen
creating a structure to support its
weight this stunning new evidence shows
that when presented with a challenge
gorillas to have the ability to use
tools to cope with their environment
much like humans do
such discoveries may help us understand
our own evolution how our earliest
ancestors made the cognitive leap to
grasp the possibilities of engineering
it just goes to show the kinds of
benefits you can see from a long-term
research presence in somewhere like in
buh-bye we could be here for hundreds of
years and still not truly uncover all
the secrets of the forest have to offer
this important research gives us a
glimpse into the minds of one of our
nearest animal relatives and perhaps
into the mists of our own distant past